who are we  what are the dominance  the power we wield  it wears away at our very being  it breaks us  it unmakes us  that it's immaculate aspect might reveal  itself  the icon  there's going to be another war isn't  there  every day we delay brings us closer to  disaster  we must move now  [Applause]  the chaos he would wreak would sweep all  of valasthir into the abyss  [Music]  i unite the dominance  that we may bring an end to the strife  and found a new order to see us unto  tomorrow  if i take the field  our duels shake the island  to its foundations  [Music]  there will be losses it is true  yet for every citizen who falls  another can be bred  for every home that burns another can be  built  the empire will live on  [Music]  awaken child of fate  awaken  everything  [Music]  playstation